and now ASAP science presents 100 digits
of pi 3.14159 this is PI followed by 2 6
5 3 5 8 9 circumference over diameter 7
9 and 3 2 3
OMG can't you see 8 4 6 2 6 4 3 and now
we're on a 338 at 32 now we're blue o
new 7950 and then a 288 and 41 and so
much fun now a run later once again 393
751 halfway done
I'm eight now don't be late 2:09 where's
the wine seven four it's on the floor
the night before my mine to 300 we gotta
go seven eight we can't wait one six
four Oh 68 we're almost near the end
keep going sixty children through eight
nine nine and ten eight six two I know
there's only a bit more than five three
four two two eleven seven Oh in 67 we're
done was that one where the random digit
so that you can break TV friends thank
you guys for watching if you want to get
the song we'll put links for iTunes and
anywhere else in the description that
you can check out study it brag to your
friends okay and make sure you subscribe
to this channel for new science weekly
videos every Thursday and we'll see you
next week see ya